欢迎大家来到胡刀刀，我是从1990年开始在电视上看世界杯，看着意大利足球长大的胡伟。
我是不看球，但每一届世界杯都会凑一下热闹的一刀。
我是现场看过世界杯的熊耳刀。
哎呀，每次提到世界杯我都特别特别羡慕熊。
熊是在20年前2006年德国世界杯的时候看过巴西对澳大利亚的比赛。
那届世界杯是我心中最长前锋罗纳尔多的最后一届世界杯，也是意大利夺冠的一届世界杯。
从那以后，意大利就进入到了一个深不可测的世界杯下行周期。
这几天世界杯快要开幕了，我就又重温了几遍天下足球的那个短节目，就叫做青春，不过是几届世界杯。
我跟那个一刀熊耳刀都吸虚了一下，就是时间的度良痕有时候不是24小时，也不是什么365天，而是这个四年。
正好我女儿是2014年出生的，那一届是巴西世界杯。
从那一年开始，我每一届世界杯跟我闺女都有一个同意位置的合影，所以对我来说真的是四年是一个新的度良痕。
您这也过于向老年人了，已经开始怀旧了。
中年老登门的必备节目，每年世界杯的时候怀旧一下。
那现在回想一下你当年看球的画面，熊你觉得还有什么印象吗，或者是比较计深刻的地方。
我的印象就是我做第一排，然后我回头合了个影，然后发给你，我问这人是谁？
他说罗娜尔多。
你这是妥妥的炫耀铁啊。
我就是当年朋友圈最亮的仔。
不过其实这都是过去的话了，然后我们这期节目主要来说说马上就要开赛的2026世界杯吧。
因为我本身也不是一个球迷，所以对球本身就不懂。
那我们今天来聊什么呢？
我们就算聊一下周边吧。
而且很多听众说他们的冷知识最近都来自于我们，我们又继续提供冷知识吧。
所以我们今天这期节目不管你是球迷还是非球迷的，你都可以听一听。
毕竟世界杯就会是未来一个多月吧，最热门的事件。
所以我们会收集00总总我们自己关心的信息。
也算是给你们未来这一个月的社交货币提前处点值。
但世界杯的信息实在是过多，反正我们也没法面面俱到。
所以欢迎大家在留言区留下你自己关心的问题，或者是你觉得本届世界杯的看点。
没准我们还会做第二期或者是第三期。
首先我觉得本届世界杯我觉得最基础的一个信息吧，或者最重要的一个信息是，
它是首次由三个国家联合举办的一个世界杯。
我记得之前印象比较深刻的是日韩两个国家举办的世界杯。
没想到这一回居然是三个国家，美加墨三国合办的。
同时呢，因为三个国家合办了嘛，阔军也到了48强，一共104场比赛。
现在夺冠的球队需要打满8场比赛。
那么这个开幕式的话呢是在北京时间6月12号的凌晨3点钟。
你不知道那天你会不会看。
对于我这种熬不起夜的人，我大概率是不会爬起来的。
所以中灯门虽然号称是球迷，
但实际上真的要熬夜看的时候，就说我还是看个那个录像吧。
不过说到这个48强，之前不是出了中国买不买世界杯转播权的这个热点新闻吗？
我就注意到了这个48强，比赛长次一下多了那么多。
但是好像里边很多队我们都不知道是什么队，
然后很多比赛也不是大家想关注的。
所以当时就有一个说法说这次比赛注水这么严重，还要收我们这么贵的转播费。
作为球迷的牛应该怎么看呢？
其实呢，这种对话以前就有过。
就是1998年法国世界杯的时候，当时是从所谓的24强扩军到了32强。
但我现在回头看，其实大家虽然嘴上都说什么注水严重，
但我也没觉得这个世界杯的热度降下来，
我觉得球迷们好像一点也没少看，讨论呢也一点都没少。
总之呢，反正因为足球毕竟是这个世界第一运动吧，这可能就是它的魅力。
而且比赛多一点，长词多一点，是不是大家更容易抢到票啊？
不管这个球票好不好抢，我觉得长词多了之后倒是能挣更多的钱，
待会我们会再展开说两句。
反过来我觉得我总是一个乐观看好处的这么一个人嘛。
就是球队扩到48只，我觉得其实也有好处。
因为呢，毕竟这个惊喜意外冷门都是每一届世界杯可能让大家印象最深刻的一个点。
那这个比赛增多了，时间也拉长了之后，那就变得一切皆有可能。
比如啊，我自己觉得这届世界杯不是扩成48只之后，它会分成12个组，
每组有4个队。
那以前是每组的前两名出现，今年除了12个组的每组前两名出现之后，
还会有8只成绩最好的小组第三名也会出现。
所以这就改变了我自己觉得小组赛的比赛的情况，
因为以前在第三轮排名第三的无法出现的时候，就很多球队就开始摆烂，
因为他们毕竟无欲无求嘛。
但是今年这个情况下，我自己觉得小组赛的最后一轮或许会变成最精彩的一轮比赛，
所以还挺值得期待的。
反正话又说回来了，就是都扩军了，就是咱中国队还是没进，这还真是有点可惜。
我怎么感觉挺像现在的音乐综艺节目，就是那些被淘汰的人要混在一起，
然后再搞一个复活赛子类是不是。
说不定下一届世界杯或者是新的一届世界杯有这个新玩法的，
因为每一年世界杯它总有一点创新的事情发生，
这一届世界杯其实跟上一届世界杯比是有很多不同的。
对，首先上一届的卡塔尔世界杯的话，应该说是历史上最紧凑的一届。
八座球场几乎都全集在首都多哈的周边，
最远的两座球场开车是不到一个小时的，
球迷甚至可以在一天内赶着看两场不同的比赛，
球队甚至都不用更换铸地酒店了。
不过如果你去过卡塔尔你就知道了，你只要开车快一点，
可能多踩几脚油门就能跨到别的国家了，
所以肯定是一个最紧凑的世界杯。
但是这次的美加莫联办那就不一样了，
毕竟北美大陆是真的很大，
而且我这次第一次知道有一个概念，
就是每个球队是有一个自己的驻地，
然后从驻地再到参赛的场馆去。
因为世界杯不像奥运会，奥运会有一个奥运村，
大家都扎堆住在一起。
世界杯的球队，
每个球队都会在比赛国选一个地方当成自己的常驻基地，
包括赛前的热身训练，
然后比赛之后的修整的地方都会在这个常驻地里。
然后问题就来了，
那个北美那么大，
从加拿大的温哥华到墨西哥的墨西哥城，
最长跨都要到4400公里，
所以有些球队就可能面临着每踢一场淘汰赛，
都要横跨几个时趋，
长达四五个小时的飞行，
这个对体能恢复和物流都还挺考验的。
比如,
这次世界杯的新军就是库拉索，
别问他是谁啊，
我们一会可能会提到他，
因为我们在这些世界杯之前完全不知道这个国家的名字，
以及他在哪，
库拉索的注定他选择在了美国的佛罗里达，
但他的比赛要在休斯敦，
堪萨斯城和费城，
所以有网友们大概做了个计算，
他踢完小组赛，
他的总飞行距离，
会达到将近11000公里左右，
这个11000公里，
就类似于从北京飞到洛杉矶的这个里程。
但我觉得看到了伊朗之后，
库拉索可能不是最酷的那个，
因为之前就有一个万众主目的问题，
伊朗到底参不参加这次的世界杯，
怎么参加？
伊朗因为美国对签证的限制，
所以他的注定原定是美国的耶利桑那州，
改为了墨西哥的定华纳士，
但是他的三场投赛赛好像都是在美国的，对吧？
所以他成了一个世界杯采用的唯一的一种模式，
就是比赛日跨境参赛，
他的驻地住在相当于美墨的边境，
距离三第二个也就20公里，
但是他的三场比赛，
我看了一下，
有两场是在洛杉矶，
有一场是在西雅图，
就是说他要从帝环那飞洛杉矶，
还要从帝环那飞西雅图，
飞洛杉矶还好，飞过去也就一个小时，
但看了看飞西雅图，中间还得转机，
所以如果他比赛完就要返回的话，
单日往返的再图时间，
可能就得10个小时以上。
这也太不公平了吧，
感觉还没开始踢球，
就已经消耗了人家很多体力了。
这些嘛我觉得心好累啊。
其实伊朗和美国之间，
在世界杯还挺有渊源的，
我们待会会有专门的一个章节去说一说，
今年他会不会遇到，
以及他过去世界杯上的战绩如何。
那其实除了距离这个问题之外，
世界杯这次的世界杯还有一个问题，
就是高海拔。
加拿大其实和美国的这个海拔还好，
基本上都很平嘛，
但墨西哥就不一样，
因为开幕式的那个场地是。
墨西哥墨西哥城的那个阿斯特克体育场，
这个体育场的海拔大概是2200米左右，
就是和西宁的海拔差不多。
根据我去年跑西宁马拉松的那个感觉，
这个竞技状态至少是要下降30%，
所以其实墨西哥这个冬道主真是天时地理人和都聚齐了，
像小赌赛有地理的优势，还是冬道主。
所以我自己觉得他今年的成绩呢，
真的是值得关注一下。
也就是说我们可以买他剩是吧，
多投一点。
低调低调。
彩票有风险，购买须谨慎啊。
而且除了这个高海拔之外还有一个问题，
就是比赛的时间，
我看了看比赛时间基本上都是从墨西哥时间的下午1点开始，
这个时候基本上就是墨西哥最热的时间了，
一天之中最热的，
所以大家除了要面对高海拔，
还要面对高温的挑战。
当然高温我觉得不仅仅是墨西哥要面对的问题，
其实那个高海拔反倒可能带来的是空气清新，
然后气温凉爽，对吧。
但下午比赛的这个时间，
其实面临的确是个高温的问题，
毕竟这个世界杯转播是要考虑各大洲的关赛的需要，
尤其欧洲是这个转播的黄金地区，
然后也是可能支付了最高转播费的一个区域，
所以得照顾欧洲球迷的这个时间。
美国的下午一点到三点之间，
大概也就是欧洲的晚上七八点钟，
也就是它的黄金时间，
所以这样子的情况下，
球迷和球员就要吃点苦了，
因为94年世界杯的时候也是在美国，
我当时印象中球员都是各种抱怨，
毕竟有些地方的温度大概会去到40度，
你想想，如果你还要奔跑，
这真的还是挺遭罪的。
所以大家今年看球赛的时候，
可能会发现一个特别之处，
就是除了上下半场中间是有一个休息时间之外，
在上下半场中还会穿插一个喝水的暂停时间，
好像是三分钟。
就让大家多喝点水，降降温，是吧？
我们既然都提到了看球的时间，
我们来看看大致一些重要比赛的时间点呗，
总体来说，今年的比赛其实是对于早起的牛马是有好处的。
但是对我们这种晚睡的人不行。
那么节目赛的话，我们该讲是在6月12号，
就是凌晨3点，
我们这里讲的都是以北京时间为例子。
那么决赛的话是7月20号的也是凌晨3点，
那么三四名的决赛呢，
7月19号凌晨4点，
半决赛呢是15、16号的凌晨3点，
大家一看就知道了，所有重要比赛都是凌晨。
小组赛和部分淘汰赛的话呢，
每天有很多场，
时间从凌晨到中午的12点都有，
早上的6点、7点、8点、10点，
甚至中午12点都有。
所以说在小组赛和32强这个阶段，
这个时间点对伟哥这种早起型的选手，
还是挺合适的。
我们总喜欢熬到12点、1点睡的话呢，
就不行了。
你要不就多熬一会，熬到3点。
看完再睡是吧？
对对对。
不过说起美国的这个世界杯，
其实让我回忆起来，
94年世界杯嘛，
就像我刚才讲的是在美国，
因为我那时候正好是初中毕业，
我现在回想起来，
我都觉得那绝对是一个非常美好的暑假。
你想早上起来，
可以一直不停的看球到午饭时间，
然后晚上呢再看一下央视的那个世界杯节目，
感觉天天都是在过节。
不过就像我刚才讲的，
就是到了32强，
比赛开始后，
这个比赛时间就开始趋向于凌晨，
我觉得我应该是不会熬这个夜了，
毕竟现在熬一个夜得还好多天。
但我后面也会提一下，
我还是有一些想看的凌晨的比赛。
不过我觉得你可以不用感叹，
你那个没有这个美好的暑假了，
你家的娃已经接过了接力棒，
我相信对于朵朵来说，
接下来也是个美好的暑假，
所以躺着吹着空调看着球。
然后在沙发这边睡一会，
然后在沙发那边睡一会，是吧？
对，那这次世界杯呢，
是第一次三国联合举办，
我们来聊聊这部分的信息吧，
首先我就不明白，
为什么是要三国举办世界杯这么好的生意，
为什么美国人不自己把它搞了，
还愿意跟人分一分呢？
我觉得为什么是三国合办呢，
其实有很多个原因，
那么一个原因其实也是为了省钱，
大家多赚一点，
因为刚才我们提到了嘛，
这些世界杯是扩军到了48个队伍，
然后场次增加到了104场，
如果让单一个国家承办的话呢，
其实这个负担是很重的，
而且呢，你想嘛，
这个每一个重大赛事，
其实最高的成本，
其实都是那个基础设施的建设，
那如果让一个国家去兴建这么多体育场，
我觉得真的是负担过重，
那与其这样的话呢，
其实就不如这个拼多多，是吧，
大家一块合资搞一个比赛，
而且你现在看美国加安大墨西哥，
其实都有过去举办这个大型赛事，
留下来的高标准的体育场，
比如说一会我们会提到的墨西哥的那个阿斯特克体育场，
那这样的话呢，
大家可以省点钱，
而且他们的基础设施交通网络，
我觉得也都算不错，
所以省下来钱，
可以让自己的收益最大化，
除了我自己觉得经济收益之外呢，
其实如果你回头看，
就是在2017、2018年的时候，
深半2026年世界杯的时候，
因为2022年这个世界杯当时已经定在了亚洲，
2018年在欧洲，
按照世界杯不能连续在同一大洲举办的原则，
所以最主要竞争这个主办权的，
就是非洲和北美洲，
他们的主要竞争对手是非洲的摩洛哥，
而且当时是有一种风声的，
是说让世界杯再次回到非洲去，
所以从气势上看呢，
摩洛哥好像是有点优势的，
所以当时美国就联合了美加墨，
这样的话呢三国联合，
这样的话呢在和摩洛哥PK的时候，
不就更有这个竞争力，
再加上呢三国联办之后呢，
也能让国际足连放心，
毕竟这个这些世界杯是第一次48对，
所以国际足连肯定也有点担心，
这样美国这个商业运作能力最强的这个国家带头，
再加上两个小地，
其实是可以让国际足连放心的，
所以我自己觉得综合这个经济因素，
综合当时竞争的这个因素，
所以就三国联合了。
那美国是不是除了这个经济因素之外，
还有其他的一些议员才愿意合作？
对，因为你回看的话呢，
当时决定这个2020年世界杯归属的时候，
那个时候是2018年，
那时候还是特朗普做总统的第二年，
所以其实不是那么严重的单边主义，
所以美国作为这个灯塔国嘛，
总有一种要拉拢这个邻国，
就是加拿大和墨西哥小兄弟的这个意象，
但这个大家都知道的，
从赚钱这个角度来说，
美国一直都是最积贼的，
所以你如果仔细去看的话，
其实这104场比赛，
加拿大和墨西哥一共只分到了26场，
而且以小组赛为主，
那也就是说几乎所有的淘汰赛的比赛，
都是在美国大陆上的，
就是说票房最好的比赛，
最赚钱的比赛全都在美国，
等于说把最好的肉留给了自己，
周围两个兄弟基本上就是喝点汤吧，
所以说到这儿你们也就理解了，
这也就符合我们对美国的这个客板印象了吧。
就是，但是另外两国虽然收益小了点吧，
但是喝了汤比赛不多，投入也不大，
分点什么转播权益啊，旅游收益啊，
作为主办国最重要是不是，
还能拿到这个保送的名额，
所以里外里算起来还是赢的。
是的，所以我觉得综合这么多因素吧，
其实就三国合办，
我觉得好像也是一个水道渠成的事儿。
那历史上多国合办的先例多吗？
我印象中是不是只有日韩呢，之前？
之前其实只有2002年的日韩联合主办世界杯，
那时候咱们不是在新疆吗？
我觉得那个时候真的是看世界杯最爽的一段时间，
不过我看网上一些评论是说，
从那届世界杯之后，
其实非法就有一个不成文的规定，
明文的讲了，就以后就不让多国办赛了。
毕竟在协调日韩这两国的时候，
当时应该是操碎了心。
那你现在看的话，真的是规矩是死的，人是活的，
你看今年的这个多国联合又回来了。
所以活久见这个词不白说是吧？
嗯，每年都是多年之未见之大变局。
我觉得主要还是因为有美国这个老大在这，
如果是墨西哥和加拿大合办的话，
只有这两个国家的话，说不定也是扯皮扯的很厉害。
对呀，一个人说了算嘛，
哎对，插播一句，其实你看，
美国又要在洛杉矶办这个2028年的奥运会，
所以其实看美国这个国家，
最近这两年是真心想赚点体育的钱，
但是目前来看，
很多国家可能对奥运会不太感冒，
是不是也可以考虑也搞这个三国联办，
四国联办，是吧？也挺好的。
对呀，据说奥主委想要中国申办2036年的奥运会，
但是已经被我们拒绝了，
奥运会已经不像以前是那么一个大家要排着对抢的香泊泊了，
现在有能力成帮或者国家，
感觉就不多，
而且还想要盈利或者不想亏太多，
这样的国家更是聊聊无几了。
另外呢，就是刚才说的那些场馆，
奥运会之后有大量的奥运场馆，
就使用了一次之后就废弃了，
没有带来太多的价值。
所以呢，单一一个国家去承办奥运会，
感觉现在已经是大家不想干的那件事了。
所以虽然奥主委是禁止多国联合举办奥运会的，
但是事意十一说不准，
没准2036年之后奥运会也多国联办了呢。
对呀，因为就像你说的这个办这种大赛，
就是虽然是有一些经济收益的，
还有一些拉动的作用，但是这个投资确实是太大。
所以我们如果回到世界杯上来看的话呢，
下一届世界杯又会是一个多国联办，
而且这次呢是跨洲的合办。
那2030年的世界杯呢会是葡萄牙，
西班牙，摩洛哥三国主办。
虽然这个摩洛哥和西班牙葡萄牙的直线距离很短，
其实就隔了个海。
据说最近距离可能就只有几十公里，
但是不管怎么说，这是创了一个新前的社，
就是以前的都是单一大洲联合举办，
这次是欧洲非洲跨大洲的举办。
而且还有一个新鲜的玩意儿，
因为下一届的世界杯是世界杯的百年纪念。
除了这三个国家联办之外呢，
还会回到乌拉圭、阿根廷、巴拉圭举办这个百年纪念赛。
所以这种又有情怀，又能让多国分担分显的这种主办模式，
也算是让国际足连在不停的复制。
所以你看很多体育人士都在讲，
如果看过去这二十年，
国际足连真的是力压国际奥尔会，
是把体育这个生意做得真的是风生水起的。
说到世界杯的投资大，
八年之后的2034年世界杯呢，将由沙特拉伯举办。
这也世界2022年卡特尔之后世界杯再次回到了土豪石油国家。
这个事情是不是也证明世界杯越来越是个有钱国家的事情。
我觉得是的，不过这里边又带出来了另外一个段子，
就是说因为考虑世界杯不能连续在一个大洲举办嘛，
那既然2034年已经是沙特了，
所以2038年也不能在中国办了。
所以我们最早可能是2042年去举办世界杯。
那也就是可能2042年之后才再次看到中国队出现在世界杯吗？
咱们别说这个，说点别的。
那伟哥你刚才讲了这个说百年世界杯的纪念回到了这个乌拉龟，
那也就是说第一届世界杯原来是在乌拉龟主办的。
没错，这也是咱们准备这期节目的时候，
我跟你们俩讲的时候颠覆了你们俩一个认知，对吧？
其实你们现在看乌拉龟好像在国际族谈有点名声，
但是也没那么大，但是如果你回头看的话呢，
当年想当年快100年前，
这个乌拉龟在足球界那真的是想当当的一个国家，
它是1924年和1928年缠连两届奥运会男族冠军的国家。
那当时回到1930年的话，当时正好是乌拉龟独立100周年，
而且它给国际族连offer的一个可能不能拒绝的福利待遇，
就是它会承担所有参赛球队的差率费用，
所以解决了大家一个心病，
因为毕竟你想想那个时候没有商用的飞机，
你想想欧洲的球队如果要去乌拉龟参赛的话，
估计得坐好几个月的船才能到乌拉龟。
但是客观来讲，现在乌拉龟的足球在世界上声音确实小了很多，
主要也是因为后面欧洲足球巴西阿根廷的崛起，
抢走了它的风头，毕竟乌拉龟的人口基础太小了，
你想和这些足球的大国或者经济实力更强的国家去绝足足球还是有点吃亏，
不过它依然还是南美洲的好强，
而且在2010年的世界杯上还拿了个第三名。
我能感叹一下吗？
乌拉龟原来当时这么有钱呀，
1930年的是个什么概念，
能可以这么大手笔的花钱，搞体育。
所以这就说了嘛，南美的国家，
每一个国家都辉煌过，
其实你回头想想，治理曾经也是特别牛的国家，
现在不是也看不到了，OK，咱们不说他们了，
这个咱们毕竟不是一个历史地理的节目，
咱们还是回到世界杯上，
其实今年春节期间吧，
应该就是春节期间，
我其实看到了墨西哥的新闻，
我当时不是给你们俩讲说，
墨西哥军方击毙了一个大毒销，
当时那个毒销的军队就进行了大规模的报复，
所以我还说，这件世界杯在墨西哥还能办嘛，
因为看当时的那个视频的画面，
包括那个媒体的新闻还是挺严重的。
而且我听说就是他们会无差别的抓人质，
以置换他们被抓的那些兄弟嘛。
后面是墨西哥政府应该是做了一个承诺嘛，
是说要投入将近10万安保人员，
然后这样那个非法就是国际足连，
才官方确认了一下，
每家墨世界杯会按计划进行。
其实你们两位都是去过墨西哥的，
你们当时去墨西哥旅行啊，
出差的时候感受如何啊？
我其实没有去过墨西哥，
但我去了哥伦比亚、哥斯达利加，
也算是比较典型的这种拉美国家。
像哥伦比亚的话呢，
也是一样就是有些繁华的大城市，
其实治安不太好，
但是一些旅游的小城市，
其实治安还可以的。
但是无论怎么样，
就是治安这块是要比较关注的一个问题，
在拉美地方旅游的时候。
对这个我跟一刀感觉是一样的，
就是我们在墨西哥城的时候，
晚上还是尽量的少出去，
这样可以避免一些风险，
反而是在那些小城镇，
像七七一茶这些地方，
还比较安全，
所以晚上我们还能去酒吧喝喝酒，
然后再走路回去这样。
不过不知道现在是什么情况，
毕竟我是2019年去的，
当时的政局都是相对稳定的。
没错，反正我们也是远隔重阳，
都是在网上了解一些信息，
可能也都比较片面。
不知道咱们这个听众朋友们，
有没有计划去看本届世界杯的，
尤其是如果要去墨西哥冠赛的，
欢迎留言啊，
到时候咱们说不定可以做一期节目，
分享一下你们的真实感受。
对刚才我们都一直在说，
美国是这个运作体育经济的强国，
那下午我们讨论的时候，
我真的是被本届世界杯的球票价格惊到了。
没错,
如果要说这一届世界杯的Tagging的话，
除了三国举办48强104场比赛之外，
还有一个Tagging，
应该就是球票最贵的一届。
因为这一届的这个球票啊，
不管是说可能常规的这个平均票价，
还是最高票价，
应该都是创造了一个纪录。
我让这个金米奈啊，
ChadGBT都分别总结了一下这个数据，
然后我觉得还是达成共识了，
比如说啊，
如果你去看常规的这个平均票价的话，
上一届卡塔尔，
大概是可能70美金左右。
这一届美加莫世界杯会去到120美金，
然后我觉得最夸张最离谱的事情是那个最高票价，
因为卡塔尔的时候，
当时应该做了一个1600美金的一个限价，
但是美加莫世界杯已经完全不一样了。
我在各种美国这个官方媒体，
甚至像什么时代周刊上都看到过，
就说像决赛的黄金作为的价格，
已经至少就是前排，
就是那个所谓叫一类座，
它会到32，970美金，
大概是24万人民币。
也就是说可以在小城市买一套房呗。
没错,
而且更夸张的是，
因为它这个票价是可以做这个二手交易的，
有些票价会标记成20万美金，
甚至什么200万美金。
当然了，我相信这个200万美金，
更多的可能是一个噱头，是一个新闻效应，
甚至我在一些美国媒体上还看到了，
就是这个非法的主席说，
如果有人真的买到了这个200万美金的票，
他要做这个服务生，
好好的服务好这个球迷。
就是这个感觉像一个服务挺好的这个主持，
至少是做得非常服务态度是做得非常好的。
200万美金一张的票服务能不好吗？
如果说到这届世界杯的价格为什么高涨的话呢，
其实有一种说法是说，
非法是首次引入了类似于像这种航空公司，
或者是网约车的那种动态定价，
也就是说会根据对手赛事的阶段举办的城市，
甚至购买的这个时间去实时波动，
所以就会出现那种很极端的情况，
就是说有一些很贵的票，
也会有一些我在网上看到的，
是那种十美金的球票。
然后做节目前，
我查了一下美国的一些官方媒体在说，
最近的普通场次的门票大概下降了20%，
所以这种门票都有一种炒股的感觉。
我在对这期节目的时候，
我闺女说是不是得给马斯克打一个电话，
让马斯克出来解救一下美国的老百姓，
让他们能看得起球。
而且听说国际主连自己还搞了一个球票的交易平台，
而且是打着官方唯一的支持这个球票交易的平台，
但是国际主连会从交易双方各收15%，
也就是说每一次交易国际主连的公司都会受到30%的佣金。
我感觉看这个比例大家就觉得很像苹果税，
也都是30%，
这国际主连还是挺会做生意的。
我觉得真的是不是一家人不进一家门，
你看在美国办的比赛跟苹果定的价真的是一模一样。
这听起来不就是一个官方倒票平台吗？
对呀，因为这个球票太贵嘛，
然后还有人在说这个国际主连不是有个口号吗？
叫FootballUnitesTheWorld,。
大家都觉得应该改成叫足球团结有前任的世界。
咱上次说的联业排队去买芯片，
咱改成联业排队去买球票的了。
说完了这个票价，咱们说个轻松的话题，
其实对我来说，对我这种老球米，
不管是这个字面意思还是非字面意思，
像我这种老球米，
其实每届世界杯看目前我最关注的一个东西，
实际上就是这个世界杯的主题曲。
这届世界杯主题曲公布之后，
大家都感慨说流水的世界杯铁打的Sakira。
哦，就是唱那个疯狂动物层主题曲的吗？
此处插入这个主题曲，没错，就是它。
不过对球米来说，Sakira是世界杯的常客，
不是疯狂动物层里面的那个歌手。
因为Sakira和世界杯结缘大概是从20年前开始的，
就是当时世界杯的这个闭幕歌曲，
就是Sakira唱的The Hips Don't Lie,。
字面之意就是屁股不说话。
然后之后她就唱了那个著名的歌曲，
就算你不看世界杯，你肯定也听过这首歌，
就是2010年南非世界杯主题曲，
就是那个Waka Waka，死数再插入。
而且她不光唱了这个主题曲，
而且从这个音乐界和世界杯的这个足协角度来说，
她开创了一个世界杯主题曲的风格，
就是非洲加拉丁的这个风格。
不过不过，说回今年这个世界杯主题曲，
她这个主题曲叫做Dai Dai，
就是咱们拼音的那个，
我还觉得这个世界杯真的挺国际化的，
发音真的是Dai，Dai就是Dai Dai。
据说这是一个意大利语，
这首歌是她和一个尼日利亚男歌手的合作。
这个意大利语的意思呢，就是加油，
Come on, let's go的这个意思。
我不是跟你们说嘛，虽然意大利没进世界杯，
但是意大利语出现了，
真是可惜可贺。
这次看上我，意大利竟然都没有入围，
而且还被狠狠扎了一刀。
这样子，这可能是意大利无处不在，
毕竟人家也是世界世界杯的冠军国家。
说回到这个世界杯主题曲的话，
其实我印象最深的，
肯定就是我看的那个，
第一届世界杯，就是1990年的意大利之下。
不光是我看的这个，
第一届世界杯我喜欢这首歌，
其实它这首歌真的很好听。
请你们欣赏一下。
然后另外一个我喜欢的这个世界杯主题曲，
我相信你们应该也听到过，
就是那个98年法国世界的冠军国家，
就是噢嘞噢嘞噢嘞，我也剪一段进来。
另外其实就是那个Sakira唱的那个Waka Waka，
This is Time for Africa,。
这三首世界杯主题曲是我最喜欢的世界杯主题曲。
我觉得大家一定要去听一下Sakira，
就是前奏一起，
只要跳过帕梅拉的小伙伴，
一定以为哦，天呐我要开始跳帕姐了，
那个前奏，大家都以为是帕姐来了。
当然了，像我这种中灯球迷，
谈到这个世界杯主题曲的话，
总有一种回忆过去的感觉，
因为这些世界杯为了吸引这个年轻人，
还出了一个合作推广曲，
据说就是为TikTok上传播用的。
对，当然演唱者的话呢，就包括Blackpink's Lisa。
大家一听这个就知道，
哎呀，是吸引这个年轻观众的吧。
我觉得真是哪有火爆的事，
哪就有Lisa。
而且她唱那个，就是特别洗脑，
就是Goose, Goose, Goose,。
你也搞不动是Goose还是Goose。
对，好像有一种这个协议种的感觉，
就是Goose在唱Goose。
但我看了那个MV，
反正我也没看他明白，
我印象最深的是，
在这个MV里边是有那个，
世界杯的那个官方授权的La Bu Bu。
既然都说到了La Bu Bu，
咱们说是本届世界杯里的中国元素吧，
那还是先说La Bu Bu，
就是中国其实在世界杯是有很多的赞助商的，
但是泡泡马特他不是赞助商，
他通过了授权的方式，
获得了Viva的官方IP使用权，
这个官方IP就是La Bu Bu，
然后穿了一个世界杯的球衣，
手捧大力神杯，
这个周边呢，
计划是6月在世界杯的各个。
主板城市的赛场周边进行展示，
而且呢，还在妈咪等一些城市开设了那个。
专属的快闪店，
我刚才说的那个，
穿着世界杯球衣，
捧着大力神杯的那个限量款La Bu Bu，
要卖，国内卖599亿只，
除了之外呢，就肯定还有盲盒，
盲盒是必不可少的，
那个茅荣卦建的盲盒，
一共有八个基础款，
还有一个隐藏款，
但是这个2026年4月2号在中国发售了之后，
线上就是秒空，
大家根本就抢不到，
而且5月中旬还推出了La Bu Bu，
和可口可乐，和viva，
2026的世界杯珍藏装，
我真的觉得这个，
泡泡马菜的营销做的可真好啊，
潮玩家体育打的是一手好牌，
就这也是另外一个扎心的事儿是吧，
虽然咱们中国国家队没去，
但是咱的La Bu Bu去了，
除了La Bu Bu,。
我们还是有裁判可以去的，
对对对，是的是的，
咱们没去踢球，
不代表咱们没人可以参加这个比赛，
现在已知是咱们有三个裁判，
大概率会出现在世界杯的赛场上，
一位是马宁，
他是主裁判，
还有一位叫做副名，
他应该就是视频助理裁判，
就是那个VR的裁判，
还有一位是周飞，
他是助理裁判，
可能算是候补吧，
所以这三个人算是成功入选，
整个世界杯的裁判组大概是170人，
所以有咱们三个裁判在里头，
而且特别要说的是说，
马宁已经不是第一次参加世界杯了，
他也参加了2022年的卡塔尔世界杯，
其实不光是裁判出现在了赛场上，
据说,
本届世界杯还会启用一套AI自动越位判定系统，
据说是联想提供的，
所以这套系统会为104场比赛做越位的自主判断，
据说还用了很多什么高精尖的3D建模视觉，
识别，各种技术，
越位的识别已经可以到毫米级，
而且识别的结果会自动推送给裁判，
大幅缩断，才判了这个判罚事件。
这感觉少了好多要吵架的点。
但是这个也是有争议，
因为以前的大家都在说，
这种体毛级的越位判断，
会大大的影响比赛的连贯性和比赛的趣味性和意外性，
那像这种毫米级，
甚至可能纳米级的这种判断，
确实是有点缺少了意外和人情味儿。
那除了我们刚才说的联想，
是本次世界杯的顶级赞助商之外，
其他一些赞助商我也有点意外，
就是海信和猛牛，
他们都是连续，
第三届是世界杯的官方赞助商了。
这个和他的生意形态实际上是有关系的，
比如说海信，
现在据说海外的收入已经占他的主流，
所以他在海外，
在世界上去做广告，
我觉得是可以理解的。
不过这个猛牛我其实一直都不吃特别明白，
这个牛奶品牌应该还是以中国国内为主，
难道他做这个广告就是为了扩展咱们中国的市场？
另外，你们是非球迷，
你们可能没印象，
猛牛其实在赞助世界杯的时候是有一个梗的，
就是梅西和猛牛牛奶的一个梗。
我到时候把图贴在收納子里，
我相信老球迷都可以脑补。
那么除了这些官方的顶级赞助商以外，
最逗的就是咖啡品牌的赞助了，
那么国内的九块九的咖啡大战，
即将打响到全世界了。
那么瑞幸的话，
赞助的是葡萄牙和西班牙，
包括这种联名的背套，
还有主题的紫带，
还有限定的银品，
比如C罗和西班牙队的主题特条，
都会在6月初开始在门店上线，
而库狄的话，
赞助的是阿根廷，
周边也会在6月8号上线，
大家都说不仅是球队，
是军力敌，
赞助商也是啊。
那么下周的咖啡得比就要开始了。
大街上看到别人手中的咖啡，
会不会大家都已经觉得是充满了火药味了？
我肯定要去抢一杯看看。
你可千万别两杯都抢啊。
问题是你手里的那杯咖啡，
可能就买中了冠军呢。
对啊,
因为阿根廷，
西班牙都是夺冠大热门，
葡萄牙还是夺冠热门里的第二，
或者是第三梯队。
好吧,
今天谈到这，
伟哥你来讲一讲，
谁会夺冠？
那我们就根据这个多买一点。
决定了我们买哪个咖啡？
这个说到谁会夺冠，
我自己觉得这都是选选，
然后呢，
我自己其实让多个AI工具，
都帮我做了个总结，
所以我下面告诉大家的，
是人工只能提供的结果，
如有雷同，
纯属巧合。
OK,
首先啊，
人工只能总结出来的规律就是说，
冠军一定会出现在，
赛前,
培律最高的前五个球队里头。
简单讲，
其实就是，
2022年的冠军阿根廷队，
当年他是在培律排行榜上，
大概排第五名，
然后2018年的冠军是法国嘛，
当时他排在培律榜的第二，
我就不展开讲了，
如果你看今年，
48个球队里边排名前五的，
培律排名前五的球队，
分别是，
西班牙，
英格兰，
法国,
巴西,
和阿根廷，
然后除了这五个球队之外呢，
还有一个，
第三梯队，
是葡萄牙和德国，
所以我们如果看这个，
世界被冠军的话呢，
大概就是出现在这七支队伍里面，
这是第一个定律，
我听来听去，
感觉必有一杯咖啡可以压重它，
那必须的，
那除了这个，
第一个定律就是，
冠军处在，
培律前五的球队里边，
以外,
第二个规律就叫做，
大热必死，
就是说，
培律第一的这个国家，
往往往往，
都没有好成绩，
甚至有些，
培律第一的国家，
都进不了八强，
那,
如果你去看，
今年的这个，
培律第一的话呢，
有一些，
博彩公司呢，
是把西班牙排在了第一，
有一些，
这个博彩公司，
是把法国排在了第一，
但是相对来说，
西班牙是，
更多的，
所以呢，
我们在这里头，
就要,
淘汰掉西班牙，
这样的话呢，
我们就只剩，
四个球队，
分别是，
法国,
巴西和阿根廷。
得，咱们明儿去买裤笛吧。
呵呵呵，
但,
但其实我之前，
其实是挺看好西班牙的，
我不是给你们讲了吗？
呃,
尤其是西班牙国家队，
公布了参赛名单之后，
我说我们要，
更多的钱，
投到这个西班牙身上去，
因为呢，
西班牙这次国家队里头，
没有一个，
黄马球员，
因为在历史上啊，
这个西班牙球队呢，
经常会有一些，
球队不和谐的因素，
呃,
大概率就是，
巴薩派和黄马派的，
争职,
那这次，
西班牙彻底团结了，
所以我其实是，
满看好西班牙，
但是,
按照以前的规律，
我们得把它淘汰掉，
如果我们再看，
第三条规律，
就是在二十一世纪，
没有任何一个，
球队会未免，
而且,
当一个球队拿到冠军之后，
它就会进入到一个诅咒，
呃,
过去六届啊，
未免冠军，
有四个，
小组出局，
有一个，
发强,
走得最远的，
就是上一届世界，
被法国，
进入到决算，
但是没有夺冠，
如果这个规律，
又成真的话呢，
我们又得把，
阿根丁淘汰掉，
所以现在，
四个球队，
就变成了三个，
就是,
英格兰，
法国,
和巴西，
那说到这儿的话呢，
我闺女，
投了法国，
我,
投了英格兰，
算了,
我还是去马兴巴克吧，
对啊,
这里都好像，
没有一个是，
咖飞赞住的，
是吧,
要问了小学生，
就是哪个球队的，
球员最帅，
我本来想把，
住,
压在那个上面的，
小学生，
支握了半天说，
好像都不怎么帅，
对,
因为我们刚才提到的，
不管是，
什么母巴佩呀，
然后,
维尼修斯呀，
好像长的，
都不是特别好看，
呃,
贝林厄母，
我闺女说，
还行吧，
如果,
卓子里八将军，
这个还算是，
可看的一个，
实在不行，
对我来说，
因为,
之前还有一个，
意大利南摩队，
然后,
这个南摩队，
没有了之后，
我觉得，
基本上，
就没有颜值了，
最后,
我俩还是达成了一支，
我俩说，
那就都支持一下，
美希吧，
不行,
我是,
C罗派的，
哈哈,
那,
说了这么多，
说一说，
哪些比赛，
是值得关注的吧，
我就不，
一个展开了，
我说一下，
小组赛里边的，
挪威对法国，
这里头就是，
哈兰德对姆巴佩，
就是目前，
世界上，
最贵的，
两个前锋之间的对决，
因为这两位的，
身价都是两个亿，
而且他们又，
分在了一个组里头，
但这场比赛，
真是有点，
嗯,
不太友好，
它是6月27号的，
凌晨三点，
我大概率，
起来瞅一眼，
然后接着睡吧，
还有一个呢，
我自己觉得，
想看的比赛呢，
是英格兰对克罗地亚，
因为这个，
是我比较喜欢的，
莫德里奇的比赛，
也就是说，
可能是，
莫德里奇，
对贝林恶姆，
也就是，
辛劳顶级，
中场的对话，
但这个比赛的时间，
也还是不好，
是这个凌晨四点，
说一个，
我觉得，
时间比较友好的比赛吧，
就是,
6月14号的六点钟，
巴西对摩洛哥，
这个就是，
典型的，
传统强队，
踢上届的这个黑马，
如果要挑一场，
这个阿根廷的话呢，
而且这个时间，
也比较好，
就是6月28号的，
早上10点钟，
是阿根廷对约旦，
毕竟呢，
上个世界盃，
阿根廷是伊比林，
输给了沙特，
然后他之后夺冠了，
所以我再看一看，
这个阿根廷和亚洲，
球队的战迹，
说不定能决定一下，
阿根廷以后的这个，
比赛成绩，
悲求弥门想问一句，
伊朗会不会跟美国对决？
对对对，
这个是咱们之前讲的，
对吧,
先说结论，
是特别特别有可能的，
所以你觉得，
这个真的就是缘分，
真的是缘分妙不可言，
这可能叫宿命吧，
对对对，
可能是宿命，
因为呢，
美国呢，
是分在了地组，
然后伊朗呢，
是分在了际组，
然后按照现在的，
这个赛成的话呢，
地组的第二名，
会对阵，
际组的第二名，
也就换句话说，
如果,
他们各拿了第二名的这句话，
我们就会看到，
美国和伊朗的这个对决，
但是,
就像我们刚才讲的，
其实这也不是他们第一次对决，
所以我自己觉得，
这两个国家，
真的是，
宿命,
而且,
更加体现了，
就是这个足球，
足球是看不见，
硝烟的战争，
他的第一次对决，
我印象特别深，
这个是在，
法国世界背上的，
而且那个时候，
其实,
舆论就把这场比赛，
渲染的，
特别特别的强烈，
因为这是，
每一断交20年之后，
这是两国，
第一次在世界级的，
足球场上，
相遇,
而且当时呢，
我自己觉得，
从安保啊，
从这个，
球迷角度来说，
也都是把，
分为拉满了，
而且当时也有一个，
我觉得小小的，
赛场上的一个，
温馨画面嘛，
首先,
他们拍了一张，
具有历史意义的，
赛前的合影，
另外呢，
在赛前，
伊朗球员，
就准备了，
象征着，
和平的白玫瑰，
送给了，
美国队，
所以这些画面，
都是在，
世界杯赛场上的，
一些,
明场面，
除了1998年那场，
法国世界杯的，
相遇之外，
他们在2022年的，
卡特尔世界杯，
也相遇了，
但是,
相比1998年的，
温馨,
在2022年,
感觉就火药味，
特别浓，
赛前呢，
美国足协，
官方社交媒体，
在发布，
小组级分榜的时候，
故意去掉了，
伊朗国旗中间的国徽，
伊朗足协，
当然是博恩大怒，
直接向非法上诉，
要求将美国队，
驱逐出世界杯，
我觉得，
在世界比赛上，
这样做，
的确是个，
非常恶劣的事情，
而结果呢，
是,
美国一比零，
胜了伊朗，
对,
2022年的时候，
是美国胜，
1998年是伊朗胜，
所以,
两队呢，
各有胜负，
不过,
2022年的时候，
我自己觉得，
让我印象深刻的时候，
就是,
比赛结束的时候，
美国的球员，
也过去安慰了，
痛哭的这个，
伊朗的球员，
我觉得，
这也是，
2022年的,
一个名场面吧，
希望,
这种体育精神，
依然保持吧，
体育是，
无国界的这件事情，
让它继续延续，
我们数以代，
这次的，
世界杯是什么样的？
因为,
这些画面，
其实都在，
原来天下足球的那个，
系列,
你不看足球，
就不会懂足球，
的那些，
画面中，
所以,
我们每次看到这些，
我觉得，
还真的是，
蛮受感动的，
好了,
我们翻个片吧，
我们,
说了球队，
说了赛程，
我们说一个，
世界,
说一个，
本届世界杯上，
吧?
我们刚才，
说过很多，
三这个数字，
那,
我们要说的，
这次的球场，
阿斯特克体育场呢，
是号称，
足球界的耶路撒冷，
它是,
全球,
唯一一座，
三次,
举办过，
世界杯赛式的球场，
又一个三出现了，
而阿斯特克的，
特殊之处，
刚才我们也说了，
它是一个，
高海拔，
在2200米的，
墨西哥城，
所以,
对球员来说，
可能,
尤其是对，
客队的球员来说，
体能可是个，
极大的考验，
另外呢，
是,
它是建在，
曾经爆发过的，
火山岩地基上的，
我觉得这个，
还挺牛的，
这个,
阿斯特克呢，
实际上是，
取自墨西哥历史上，
最强盛的那个，
原住民帝国，
其实也是，
这个,
每周,
三大文明之一，
呃,
大家如果知道的话，
每周的三大文明，
分别是，
印加文明，
马亚文明，
阿斯特克文明，
那,
这个球场的，
呃,
巅峰时期啊，
是可以容纳，
十一万名观众的，
目前改造之后，
大概是有这个，
八万多，
这个,
观众的这个容量，
大家可以想象一下，
哇,
这么多人，
在一个球场上，
然后那个声浪，
不敢想，
那真的是，
镇尔玉龙啊，
这里,
是不是有很多，
经典战役啊？
说到这个，
阿斯特克球场，
的确有，
特别特别多的，
在这儿踢，
其中,
就有,
1970年的,
两场比赛，
第一场，
我们要提到的，
就是,
1970年,
世界杯的，
半决赛，
这个被，
国际足连，
官方定义为，
世纪之战，
就是,
意大利，
四比三，
战胜,
西德的，
这场比赛，
那场比赛，
首先的是，
意大利，
1比0领先了，
大概八十多分钟，
然后,
西德队在，
九十分钟，
球里边的一个，
明场面，
就是,
当时,
西德足球的，
足球皇帝，
bacon bowler,。
因为当时，
他因为受伤，
肩膀脱旧，
本来要换下，
但是因为，
换人名额，
已经用完，
所以他就是，
打着崩带，
踢完了整个比赛，
所以,
让人真的是，
非常的感动，
非常的这个，
印象深刻，
而且,
据说,
现在,
在阿斯特克球场之外，
还为,
这个,
这场球，
其实也都是，
世界杯在做回顾的时候，
可能,
永远不会落下的，
一场比赛，
那，除了，
这场比赛之外呢，
自然而然，
就有1970年的，
世界杯决赛，
在,
阿斯特克球场，
巴西,
4比1,
战胜了意大利，
哎呀,
又是意大利，
所以,
我喜欢的这个，
母队,
过去,
曾经真的是，
非常非常强，
那,
因为呢，
在,
在中呢，
意大利，
只能给，
那只,
华丽的巴西队，
做了个背景板，
而且,
这个,
球赛,
结束之后，
三次夺冠的巴西队，
永久的，
保留了，
世界杯的，
纪念杯，
巴西也成为了，
唯一一个，
永久拥有，
世界杯的国家，
所以,
你想想，
这个,
球场,
能不传奇吗？
但,
这两场比赛，
对我来说，
我觉得，
让我印象最深的，
最深的，
就是,
马拉多纳，
在1986年,
四分之一决赛中间，
对英格兰的这场比赛，
这场比赛里头，
有两个，
世界杯，
的名场面，
一个名场面，
就是,
上帝之手，
大家想想，
在足球场上，
马拉多纳，
用手,
打进了一个球，
这个,
也算是一个，
美丽的错误，
因为,
他进了这个球之后，
出现,
所以,
判这个分是有效的，
然后,
除了这个，
上帝之手之外，
还有一个，
世界最佳进球，
出现在这里，
就是,
马拉多纳，
狂奔六十米，
连过,
六个英格兰球员，
打进的那个，
进球,
我相信，
说到这儿，
大家都能，
想象得到，
这就是这个，
阿斯特克体育场，
曾经承载过的，
世界杯记忆，
嗯,
所以,
还是,
特别让人期待的，
对,
会不会，
再创辉谎？
那,
聊完这个，
体育场馆之后，
我们来聊聊，
这个,
首次参赛的国家，
我觉得，
这个还挺有意思的，
那么,
首次参赛国家呢，
有,
博德角，
胡拉索，
乌兹别克斯坦，
和约旦，
是不是，
有个国家，
连你这种，
中东小王子，
都没有听说过，
前两个国家，
严格地说，
还真的是，
一般,
大家都没听说过，
我们甚至，
第二个国家，
连之前，
都没有，
就是,
没有任何印象，
有存在这个国家，
它太小了，
那,
先来看这博德角吧，
就是,
非洲博德角，
是一个位于，
大西洋的，
火山群岛，
人口只有，
不到,
五十五万，
五十四点六万，
这比中国，
很多县城，
都要少人，
他们可是，
世界杯上，
历史上，
第三小的参赛国，
仅次于这个，
冰岛,
和这个，
克力尼达，
和多巴哥，
你看这名字，
不熟的，
都没见过，
对,
那博德角，
在非洲预选赛中呢，
他居然，
赢了这个，
卡麦龙这种，
传统的强队，
以小组第一，
直接出现，
像我这种，
不怎么看球的，
都知道，
卡麦龙，
其实还是挺强的，
那我来说说，
大家特别特别，
不熟的这个，
库拉索吧，
我觉得他，
属于更夸张的，
面积只有，
四百四十四，
平方公里，
五万,
感觉还没有，
天同院大，
是世界杯游史以来，
面积最小，
人口最少的，
参赛地区，
我也是经到了，
就这么一个地区，
怎么就能出现了呢，
其实他是属于，
荷兰王国的自治国，
我也第一次，
听说有，
这种形式，
所以他的，
整个足球，
DNA里边,
都是荷兰足球，
留下的血液，
他的经济之路，
也挺魔幻的，
是在,
中北美和，
加勒比海的，
预显算中呢，
三胜三平，
靠着这种，
不败的战机，
拿下了，
B组第一，
而且,
最后一轮是，
零比零，
B平,
雅买加，
锁定出现权，
他的球队里，
是有很多的，
荷兰一球员的，
这两个国家呢，
其实都在，
那种,
夺冠大，
热的那种，
分组里头，
像福德角，
和西曼亚在一组，
然后,
库拉索呢，
和德国在一组，
所以我相信呢，
咱们在，
未来,
肯定会看到，
他们的信息，
那另外两个，
其实都是亚洲的，
呃,
首次参赛的代表，
一个是乌兹别克，
呃,
他也是，
拼了二十多年，
才首次进级世界盃，
还有一个就是约旦，
然后,
而且约旦这次，
我觉得，
让人更惊奇的时候，
他是,
拿了,
地组的第一，
力压韩国，
也算是，
首次参赛的这个，
代表,
其实除了这四职球队之外，
这一次世界盃里头，
还有一个国家，
让我其实挺意外的，
就是海地，
也进了世界盃，
因为,
海地这几年，
在我心中，
实际上就是一个，
典型的，
政治瘫痪，
安全失控，
而且经济崩溃的这个国家，
但,
他竟然，
也踢进了这个世界盃，
让我自己觉得，
听到的时候，
我自己觉得，
真的是不可思议啊，
海地在很长时间，
我听到的都是，
因为,
巨峰啊，
台峰袭击是吧，
没想到，
他也杀进了世界盃，
而且他这一次，
是和,
巴西,
摩洛哥，
一组,
所以我自己觉得，
到时候，
我真的想给他，
加个油，
那这次世界盃，
还有一个，
非常热门的话题，
然后说出来，
有一点，
忧伤的话题，
就叫做，
诛神的黄昏，
我们,
如果不说诛神的话，
我们先说，
两个神嘛，
实际上就是，
梅西,
和,
塞罗,
对,
梅西,
是我们这种，
不看球的人，
也都知道的，
他在,
2022年的时候，
卡塔就拿到了，
完成了这个，
卒谈的大满冠，
所以对他来说，
这一次，
嗯,
毕竟是在美国嘛，
是吧,
举办的，
他又在效率，
迈阿弥国际，
那么,
这应该是一场，
卒场的巡演吧，
就是不知道，
这一次黄昏中，
他是享受比赛，
还是,
再来一次精靴，
甚至,
未免冠军，
说梅西，
肯定得说塞罗吧，
这个,
我们家的小朋友，
我们,
跟自己球队的，
这个,
和梅西都炒翻天了，
那,
这也是，
塞罗的第六届世界杯，
所以,
其实,
梅西和塞罗，
也创造了个历史，
是,
目前,
啊,
唯一,
二,
两个,
参加过六届世界杯的球员，
那,
当然了，
塞罗的年纪更大一点，
已经41岁了，
我自己觉得，
他已经，
不可能在，
提出以前，
巅峰期的状态了，
所以更多的，
像是一种，
呃,
另外我自己觉得，
也是,
这个球队的，
精神弹梦吧，
那,
这两个球员，
在世界杯上的走向，
我自己觉得，
还是蛮期待的，
啊,
因为,
毕竟在，
现在这种，
快餐足球下，
像这种老将，
啊,
应该本身，
就是个传奇，
我觉得，
今天,
小学生，
又告诉了一个冷知识，
我第一次知道，
塞罗比梅西大，
因为,
我无论，
如果看脸的话，
我都觉得，
梅西更老一些，
除了说，
梅西和，
塞罗之外，
其实我还，
比较关注，
另外三个，
老将,
一个就是，
我刚才已经提到的，
就是,
科罗迪亚的核心，
就是莫德里奇，
啊,
因为我们刚才也讲过，
这个也是，
啊,
莫德里奇，
应该最后一届世界杯，
他已经，
四十岁，
所以我自己，
其实还蛮期待，
他这一届世界杯的表现，
到底如何，
啊,
另外,
大家注意啊，
他也是，
过去这几年，
梅罗,
对,
金球奖垄断的一个球员，
所以,
很期待，
他的这个，
表现到底如何，
还有一个，
其实让我有点意外的，
就是德国的守门员，
啊,
因为,
诺依尔，
就是也四十岁了，
我没想到，
最后最后，
他还是，
入选了德国股家队，
我相信，
他应该是，
最后一届世界杯了，
啊,
诺依尔呢，
其实也是目前，
这个,
门位,
就是,
门将踢后位，
或者门将，
这个,
流派的这个，
开创者，
然后,
除了这两位之外呢，
啊,
我还比较关注，
内马尔，
啊,
其实,
曾经是，
大家心中，
梅希和，
希罗,
之外的，
足球界的，
第一人，
但是,
因为这几年，
他的,
伤病也，
嗯，不停，
所以,
已经没有什么，
太好的，
表现,
他能,
入选,
所以,
我自己觉得，
说不定，
他还能爆发一下，
毕竟,
他也只有34岁，
但是,
除了这些，
即将退役的，
老将之外，
我觉得，
新的王，
是不是也要诞生了，
毕竟,
现在,
有那么贵的球员，
啊,
没错,
我们,
只要一提，
诸神皇魂，
另外要出现了，
四个字，
就是,
新王当力，
哈哈,
那,
呃,
最前例的，
进入到一个，
两亿欧元的时代，
啊,
我们刚才讲过，
其实,
哈兰德和姆巴佩，
身价是两亿，
其实,
除了这两位以外，
还有一位，
18岁的亚马尔，
目前的身价，
也是两亿，
所以,
这三个人，
我自己觉得，
在世界盃上的表现，
也就换句话说，
西班牙，
挪威,
法国,
在世界盃上的表现，
还是蛮值得期待的，
尤其,
我最想看的，
就是,
不知道会，
撞出什么样的火花，
呃,
身价不是我关心的，
可惜,
没有颜值在线的，
哈哈,
翻篇了，
刚才都说了，
意大利南摩之后，
已经没有帅哥了，
哈哈,
那,
说到这里，
本期节目，
快到了最后的时段，
我不得不说，
几句,
我们的邻居，
日本队，
嗯,
哎呀,
对,
作为一个，
中国球迷角度来说，
说到日本队，
我自己觉得，
总有一种，
他,
上一届世界盃，
在死亡小组里，
连着办了德国队，
连着办了，
西班牙，
而且最近，
又赢了，
像巴西这样的球队，
所以,
你说让人不羡慕的话，
那是不可能的，
但,
我自己觉得，
咱如果，
自我安慰的话呢，
至少,
告诉大家，
如果你坚持的话，
如果你花上二十年，
三十年，
然后遵守这个，
足球的规律的话，
还是有得搞的，
算了,
这个,
这个事情，
我们就，
不展开说了，
可以做下一期节目，
来谈一谈中国队，
谈一谈，
什么样的国家，
才能提好足球？
咱们就吵好了，
看看呗，
就不说中国青年队，
看看我们的少年队，
胡同同学，
有一次，
踢完回来，
我们队六比零，
赢了他们，
我说,
你是打篮球吗？
我们,
闺女这个球，
现在踢的也，
比较殆尽，
其实如果说到，
中国国家的少年队，
或者青年队吧，
也不错，
最近,
刚刚结束的，
第一比赛里头，
我们拿了亚洲的第二名，
而且在半决赛里，
是赢了澳大利亚，
在决赛里边，
三比零落后的时候，
还追了两个球，
所以让我，
还是产生了一些，
希望之光，
所以说到这儿的话，
我只能，
预祝中国足球，
是越来越好的。
那我们本期节目，
就先录到这呗，
关于世界呗的话题，
有非常多，
那欢迎大家留言，
写下你们想聊的话题，
或许我们可以，
再录一期哦。
虽然我不是球迷，
但是大夏天的半晚，
习克共养丹遮，
跟朋友去喝杯啤酒，
看了球，
这感觉也还是挺不错的。
这个看球，
是个挺好的借口。
没错,
我觉得夏天，
就应该搞这些事情。
虽然熊呢，
都一直在禁止我，
这个感慨，
但我最后还是，
感慨一下吧。
就是,
呃,
我最近会，
嗯,
不停的看一些，
可能天下足球的，
这种,
过往的，
这种世界碑的系列，
尤其,
我看了好多遍，
就是你不看足球，
你就不会懂，
呃,
这个系列，
很多原来，
美好的回忆啊，
和足球啊，
和夏天的，
很多故事，
都,
出现在了我脑海中。
所以呢，
我就想说，
大家在这个夏天，
就,
尽情的享受吧。
不管你是不是球迷，
我就,
都祝大家，
看的愉快，
玩的开心。
嗯,
画老整就世界。
让世界更精彩，
拜拜。
谢谢。
我,
穿世界碑球服，
举大力，
神碑的。
安排，安排。
我就差说，
得我们十万粉丝，
才给嘛。
都抢不到了。
我还想说，
要不在，
留言的这个，
听众中抽一个，
算了,
这个不能，
不能说。
这个不是有钱，
都能拿得到的感觉。
对。
谢谢,
拜拜。